تم الكشف عن كل هذا فوق بحر الصين
الجنوبي يوم الأربعاء الماضي في 21 كانون الأول (ديسمبر)
، ألق نظرة على هذا الفيديو الذي تشاهده
J11 صيني من جيش التحرير
الشعبي وترى ذلك من قمرة القيادة
لطائرة أمريكية ومفصل برشام RC-135
وهو بالأحرى  طائرة استطلاع كبيرة
بطاقم مكون من حوالي 30 شخصًا في الداخل ،
يمكنك بالفعل رؤية مدى قربك ،
ثم ترى الطائرتين
تنجرفان بالقرب من بعضهما البعض ، وذلك عندما
تقول القيادة الهندية المحيطية إن هذه كانت
مناورة غير آمنة من خلال j11 الصينية
برشام RC-135  عندما نزلت الطائرة الأمريكية
بعيدًا ، يمكنك أن ترى أنها تبتعد
عن بعضها البعض بحيث لا يكون هناك أي
تفاعل أوثق بين الاثنين
أو خطر حدوث تصادم هناك
وهذا بالطبع هو مصدر القلق الكبير هنا وهذا
فقط يضيف التوتر بين بكين
وواشنطن ، وهناك
بالتأكيد ما يكفي من ذلك هنا ،
ترى التوتر أيضًا حول
بحر الصين الجنوبي الذي تصر الصين على أن معظم
المياه المتنازع عليها هي أرضها السيادية
لم تدرك الولايات المتحدة هذا
الادعاء الذي تصر على أنها ستطير وتبحر
حيثما يسمح القانون الدولي بالذئب ،
هناك تفاعلات بشكل عام بين
طائرات من جيوش مختلفة في
الجو آمنة ومهنية ،
يقول مسؤول دفاعي إن هذا بالتأكيد
لم يكن واحدًا من هؤلاء وسوف يثيرون
مع الجيش الصيني من خلال
القنوات المناسبة